[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en continuant à communiquer ou peu de
gêne à dire mon nom ma tempe avec moi
votre compte en centaines au départ de
burning
[Musique]
où
constance il est donc permise de rab et
nautisme est envisagée pour partir en
vacances ou part en vacances on oui oui
je pars dans ces minutes tient
maintenant tout avec mes robes on voit
comme ça donc ce menu et moi descendre
de 3,6 moment tout se voit fort pour
tout parent d'enfant et ne serrerai
jamais la campagne chez ma cousine
si les gens partent toutes mes robes et
de moi dans ma valise oubliée des deux
balises
je n'ai pas tué je compte sur toi tu
rentres in ou maryse hilton valises bon
moi je ne sais pas si je vais sûrement
me titille sa vie on valises à lille au
final il se fait toujours à une superbe
à lui ou à ne donneront plus il faut la
vide comme à moi heureusement ce bric à
brac à voilà comme temps est parfait
regarde vers nous elle te plaît
hellénistique houlette y trouver du côté
des maillots par la dèche à nous parce
qu'en 10 à 6 j'ai fait des radios
vaillac cas il a fallu cette prime
je les vois ton dans les wagons ils ont
les wagons en eau
or pour ça scandaleux on avisera valises
et on l'a emporté qu'une valise
historique avec laquelle je fais trois
fois le joueur du monde
bon je vais faire une enquête il faut
que justice soit faite je me rends
pendante et lescuriens le regard
attendait à fermer les voies la suite
prêté darty il devra le dire au revoir à
mon sport pour le plaisir
qui a raison c'est pourquoi ce que si
gentil pour nous et avec moi bien
tel cochon symbole du kabar alice à des
palois mais l'orage
non c'est jamal ma valise de lavalas aux
journalistes je reprends construction de
mon bien pensé bien faire déjà rempli
jamais vidéo elle voilà de très près
justice est faite
ma valise et aboie on a été content
quand je dis au revoir car titus mais
j'étais par terre tellement les ans
disparue qui trichent
je ne peux pas partir en vacances on va
la retrouver
pourquoi savoir où et voilà que tout est
rangé et les riant non eh bien je suis
content content route
j'ai encore cinq minutes devant joie je
vais dire au revoir à ce charme oscars
qui restent ici
la voilà peut-être que l'on termine
évidemment qu'elle avalise d'anelka il
en a pas besoin
il ya quand même tout son matériel dans
la poste est la voix c'est la balise
vite remplie sont là entre coulton bref
une valise comme ça moi j'en connais qui
l'homme voudrait bien ça y est elle est
prête à les revoir au père émile les
adieux le plus courtes sont les
meilleures
tiens réseau tice va immersive couple
est valide
ouais je t'écrirai ou un la balise à
présent voilà que jamais le cas
quelques envies comment bien de ma
plante et après tu empruntes d'une autre
étoile ne te l'a rencontrée quand nous
rendrons d'un bâton